أنت تطير على متن طائرة ذات
سطحين في الأربعينيات من القرن الماضي وفي الجو. لقد خرجت من
قمرة القيادة وتمشي على طول
الطريق الذي يجب أن أفعله
[موسيقى]
اسمي مارلين ماسون وأنا
المالك الشريك  في أكاديمية ماسون للمشي على الأجنحة
ونعلم الناس كيفية التسلق
على متن الطائرات ، إنه المكان الوحيد في
العالم الذي يمكنك حقًا أن تأتي فيه وتتعلم هذه
المهارة ، أول شيء نعلمه للناس هو
الصعود إلى الجناح العلوي ثم
الأمر يتعلق  فقط نوعًا ما من تخصيص بعض
الوقت على الأرض ، فقط قم بممارسة تلك
التحركات مرارًا وتكرارًا ومن ثم من
هناك فقط التركيز حقًا على
كل خطوة تالية من تلك الساق اليسرى لأعلى
، والآن يمكنك البدء في العمل
تحت تلك الأسلاك التي يمكنك  اجلس على هذا
الجزء ، حسنًا ،
ليس شعورًا آمنًا جدًا ، فلدينا كل شخص
يرتدي حزام أمان
وكابلًا حتى يتم توصيلهم بطائرة
لم نواجه أي مشكلة على الإطلاق ، ونعلم دائمًا الناس
الاحتفاظ بثلاث نقاط اتصال في جميع
الأوقات ، إنه أكثر أمانًا.  أعتقد أن معظم
الناس يعتقدون
بشكل مفاجئ أنني لست كذلك  توتر بقدر ما
اعتقدت أنه يجب أن يكون المرء حيث
[موسيقى]
يا إلهي ، لقد كان هذا
بالتأكيد أروع شيء فعلته على الإطلاق ، هناك نذهب
للتمشية في الجناح ، هذا للتحقق مما هو
التالي
[موسيقى  ]